Lo qué es una decisión bien intencionada para uno
es una censura absoluta para la siguiente.
Lo que ahora sabemos es que esta cuenta, Texas Lone Star,
fue parte de una campaña de desinformación rusa más amplia,
una que desde entonces ha sido eliminada.
¿Eso cambiaría su punto de vista?
Cambiaría el mío,
porque ahora se trata de una campaña coordinada
para sembrar discordia.
Y para quienes les gustaría pensar
que la IA resolverá todos nuestros problemas,
creo que estaremos de acuerdo que estamos muy lejos
de que la IA pueda dar sentido a publicaciones como esta.
Así que me gustaría explicar tres problemas entrelazados
que hacen que esto sea tan complejo
y que luego piensen en formas para abordar estos desafíos.
Primero, simplemente no tenemos una relación racional con la información,
Tenemos una emocional.
Simplemente, no es cierto que más hechos harán que todo esté bien,
porque los algoritmos que determinan qué contenido vemos
están diseñados para recompensar nuestras respuestas emocionales.
Y cuando tenemos miedo,
narraciones demasiado simplificadas, explicaciones conspirativas
y el lenguaje que demoniza a los demás es mucho más efectivo.
Y además, muchas de estas empresas,
su modelo de negocio está unido a la atención,
lo que significa que estos algoritmos estarán sesgados hacia la emoción.
Segundo, la mayor parte del discurso del que estoy hablando aquí es legal.
Seria un asunto diferente
si hablara de imágenes de abuso sexual infantil
o contenido que incita a la violencia.
Puede ser perfectamente legal publicar una mentira absoluta.
Pero la gente sigue hablando de eliminar contenido "problemático" o "dañino",
pero sin una definición clara de lo que quieren decir,
incluyendo a Mark Zuckerberg,
quien recientemente pidió una regulación global para moderar el habla.
Y mi preocupación es que vemos gobiernos
en todo el mundo
implementar decisiones políticas apresuradas
que podrían desencadenar consecuencias mucho más graves
cuando se trata de nuestra charla.
E incluso si pudiéramos decidir qué charla dejar o eliminar.
Nunca hemos tenido tantas charlas.
Cada segundo, se suben millones de piezas de contenido
de personas de todo el mundo
en diferentes idiomas
aprovechando miles de diferentes contextos culturales.
Simplemente nunca hemos tenido mecanismos efectivos
para moderar la libre expresión a esta escala,
ya sea impulsada por humanos o por tecnología.
Y en tercer lugar, estas empresas (Google, Twitter, Facebook, WhatsApp)
son parte de un ecosistema de información más amplio.
Nos gusta echarles toda la culpa a ellos, pero la verdad es que los medios
y los funcionarios electos también pueden desempeñar un papel igual
en amplificar rumores y conspiraciones cuando quieren.
Como podemos nosotros, al reenviar sin pensar contenido divisivorio o engañoso
sin estar seguros.
Estamos agregando más a esa contaminación.
Sé que todos estamos buscando una solución fácil.
Pero simplemente no la hay.
Cualquier solución tendrá que implementarse
a gran escala, escala de Internet,
y sí, las plataformas, están acostumbradas a operar a ese nivel.
pero ¿podemos y debemos permitirles que solucionen estos problemas?
Ciertamente lo están intentando.
Estamos de acuerdo en que no queremos que sean
las corporaciones globales las guardianas de la verdad y equidad en línea.
Y también creo que las plataformas estarían de acuerdo con eso.
Y en este momento, están marcando su propia tarea.
Les gusta decirnos
que las intervenciones que están implementando funcionan,
pero como hacen sus propios informes de transparencia,
no se puede verificar independientemente lo que realmente está sucediendo.
(Aplausos)
Y seamos claros que la mayoría de los cambios que vemos
solo suceden después de que los periodistas inicien una investigación
y encuentren evidencia de sesgo
o contenido que rompe las pautas de su comunidad.
Sí, estas compañías tienen que jugar de verdad un papel importante en el proceso,
pero no pueden controlarlo.
¿Y qué hay de los gobiernos?
Muchos creen que la regulación global es nuestra última esperanza.
en términos de limpieza de nuestro ecosistema de información.
Pero lo que veo son legisladores que luchan por mantenerse al día
con los rápidos cambios en la tecnología.
Y peor, trabajan en la oscuridad,
porque no tienen acceso a los datos
para entender lo que está sucediendo en estas plataformas.
Y de todos modos, ¿en qué gobiernos confiaríamos para hacer esto?
Necesitamos una respuesta global, no nacional.
Entonces el eslabón perdido somos nosotros.
Son esas personas que usan estas tecnologías todos los días.
¿Podemos diseñar una nueva infraestructura para soportar información de calidad?
Bueno, creo que podemos
y tengo algunas ideas sobre lo que realmente podríamos hacer.
En primer lugar, si nos tomamos en serio atraer al público a esto,
¿podemos inspirarnos en Wikipedia?
Nos han mostrado lo que es posible.
Si, no es perfecto
pero han demostrado que con las estructuras correctas,
con una perspectiva global y mucha, mucha transparencia,
puedes construir algo que se ganará la confianza de las personas.
Tenemos que encontrar una manera de aprovechar la sabiduría colectiva
y la experiencia de todos los usuarios.
En particular las mujeres, las personas de color
y los grupos subrepresentados.
¿Porque adivinen qué?
Son expertos en odio y desinformación,
porque han sido los objetivos de estas campañas durante mucho tiempo.
Y a lo largo de los años, han levantando banderas,
y no han sido escuchados
Esto tiene que cambiar.
¿Podríamos construir una Wikipedia para la confianza?
¿Podríamos encontrar una forma en que los usuarios realmente proporcionen ideas?
Podrían ofrecer ideas sobre decisiones difíciles de moderación de contenido.
Podrían comentar
cuando las plataformas decidan implementar nuevos cambios.
Segundo, las experiencias de las personas con la información son personalizadas.
Mi fuente de noticias de Facebook es diferente de la de Uds.
Igual sus recomendaciones de YouTube.
Eso hace que sea imposible para nosotros examinar
qué información está viendo la gente.
Entonces ¿podríamos imaginar desarrollar
algún tipo de repositorio abierto centralizado para datos anonimos,
con privacidad y preocupaciones éticas incorporadas?
Porque imaginen lo que aprenderíamos
si construyeramos una red global de ciudadanos preocupados
que quisieran donar sus datos sociales a la ciencia.
Porque sabemos muy poco
sobre las consecuencias a largo plazo del odio y la desinformación
sobre las actitudes y comportamientos de las personas.
Y lo que sabemos,
la mayoría se ha llevado a cabo en EE. UU.
a pesar del hecho de que es un problema global.
Necesitamos trabajar en eso también.
Y tercero,
¿podemos encontrar una manera de conectar los puntos?
Ningún sector, y mucho menos sin fines de lucro, start-up o gobierno,
va a resolver esto
Pero hay personas muy inteligentes en todo el mundo.
trabajando en estos desafíos,
de redacciones, sociedad civil, academia, grupos activistas.
Pueden ver algunos aquí.
Unos construyen indicadores de credibilidad de contenido.
Otros verifican hechos, para que las plataformas
puedan clasificar noticias falsas, videos e imágenes
Una organización sin fines de lucro, First Draft,
trabaja con redacciones normalmente competitivas del mundo
para ayudarlos a desarrollar programas de investigación y colaboración.
Danny Hillis, un arquitecto de software,
está diseñando un nuevo sistema llamado The Underlay,
un registro de todas las declaraciones públicas de hechos
conectado a sus fuentes,
para que las personas y los algoritmos puedan juzgar mejor lo que es creíble.
Y los educadores de todo el mundo están probando diferentes técnicas.
para encontrar formas de hacer que la gente critique el contenido que consume.
Todos estos esfuerzos son maravillosos, pero están trabajando en silos,
y muchos de ellos no tienen fondos suficientes.
También hay cientos de personas muy inteligentes.
trabajando en esas empresas,
pero de nuevo, esos esfuerzos pueden sentirse desarticulados,
porque están desarrollando diferentes soluciones a los mismos problemas.
¿Cómo encontrar una manera de unir a las personas
en una ubicación física por días o semanas,
para que puedan abordar estos problemas juntos,
pero desde sus diferentes perspectivas?
¿Podemos hacer eso?
¿Podemos construir una respuesta coordinada y ambiciosa,
una que coincida con la escala y la complejidad del problema?
Realmente creo que podemos.
Juntos, reconstruyamos nuestros bienes comunes de información.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)